- [Voiceover] When
counting by 100s from 43
to 1,043, which numbers will we say?
Select all that apply.
So let's do that.
Let's start with 43 , and then
let's just keep adding 100 to 43.
So if we add 100 to 43,
we're going to get 143.
Now let's keep adding 100 to it.
If we add another 100, we're now going to
have two hundreds and 43, or 243.
Now let's keep adding 100 to it.
So if we add another 100
we're going to have 343.
I think you see what's going on here.
You add 100 again,
you're going to have 443.
I'm coloring in the 100s place
so that we can keep track of that.
You add another 100,
you're going to have 543.
Then add another 100,
you're going to have 643.
Add another 100, you're going to have 743.
Let's keep adding 100, keep adding 100.
Add another 100, you're going to have 843.
Add another 100, you're going to have 943.
Or you can do that as
nine hundreds and 43.
Or nine hundreds and
four tens and three ones.
And let's add another 100.
So if you add another
100, you could view this
as 10 hundreds and 43.
But 10 hundreds is the
same thing as 1,000.
So we would read this as 1,043.
And that's what they
wanted us to count up to
1,043 is the same thing
as 10 hundreds and 43.
So which of these numbers did we see
when we counted from 43 to 1,043?
Well we didn't see 44.
We didn't see 123.
But we did see 143, so we did see 143.
We saw 543, we saw 543.
And we saw 843.
So we saw these numbers.
Now you might have been able
to do this in your head.
You might have said, "OK
43, then 143, then 243,
343, 443, 543, 643, 743,
843, then 943 and then 1,043.
Either way, these are the numbers
that we said when we
counted from 43 to 1,043.
These are three of the
numbers that we said.